[Música]
a nossa luta no marajó
a gente fala de marajó desconhecido
a gente fala de um marajó que o pessoal
usa muito só no contexto do turismo no
contexto da divulgação da para fora
a nossa luta vem num contraponto ela vem
falar daquele povo esquecido aquele povo
invisível as políticas públicas nas
margens dos rios e da riqueza e da
grandeza que o marajó tem
nós somos um povo guerreiro nós somos
lutadores nós temos a nossa riqueza mas
infelizmente obrigados a viver com a
exclusão social
o mar a jóia não é visto de forma que
ele ele merece então muito cedo nós
entramos na luta porque entendo vocês é
o seguinte toda a nossa a nossa riqueza
toda a nossa cultura é essa que ana é
comercializada de forma diferente a
nossa história a nossa luta
hoje por exemplo no contexto da educação
não temos nenhuma matéria que leve a a a
resgatar esse nosso histórico a manteve
isso aqui na escola
nós importamos uma educação relatada do
sul onde nenhum dos nossos livros a
nossa comercialização é de nome a nossa
identidade está comercializada não mas
para fora
então a nossa luta dentro do movimento
social é por esse reconhecimento é usado
como celeiro doutores por pesquisas
graduamos potencializamos os formadores
de opinião dentro da sociedade
nós não temos nenhuma volta em forma de
desenvolvimento então a nossa luta é
trazer à tona
do movimento social do território da dos
sindicatos das comunidades eclesiais de
base por nosso carimbó a nossa culinária
a nossa cultura
ela é única ela não existe mais em canto
nenhum e é com essa sequência com essa
força de guerreiros marajoaras da
história nos traz aí um dos povos
machico mas posso dizer dispostos a
vencer suas batalhas é que a gente vem
trazer nós no meu papel de liderança eu
procuro oportunizar todos os espaços de
divulgação para que a gente não veio
aqui questionar mas trazer alerta buscar
parceiros para que a gente possa
desenvolver mecanismos que possam estar
levando a gente a resgatar aquilo que
nós hoje marajuara tem orgulho em poucos
territórios em pouquíssimos talvez eu
não conheço porque eu faço parte da rede
nacional de territórios da cidadania da
rede estadual de colegiados em poucos
lugares você pergunta de onde tu és o
cabouco o caboclo marajoara de som do
marajó depois de dias a cidade que lhe
pertence
em outros lugares o pessoal de sensores
cidade x ou y mas no marajó acabou logo
dizer sou do marajó e depois de onde
então nós temos uma identidade própria e
buscamos fazer valer isso através de
tudo isso que nós temos só que eu volto
a dizer nós temos que ser protagonista
na nossa própria história nós precisamos
de parceiros de conhecimento de
estrutura de política pública mas não
podemos afogar nossa história nossas
lendas dos nossos mitos eu critico a
alguma alguns estudantes alguns
pesquisadores que tentam provar que as
nossas lendas dos nossos mitos são não
são verdadeiros
isso nos mantém vivo isso protege áreas
isso mantém nossa cultura porque no
momento que uma pesquisadora um
pesquisador doutor seja lá o que for
o negócio aqui não existe ele está
matando parte do meu povo parte da minha
história e eu sou contra isso isso aqui
para nós não é só uma uma lenda
da e isso está gerando recursos para
outros territórios para para outros
mecanismos
nossa nossa cultura que nós trouxemos
nosso jeito de confeccionar novos
apetrechos de pesca de caça de manter
hoje a preocupação global é preservar
preservar preservar mas ele está
preocupado com o capitalismo não ser
humano
eles querem preservar para as grandes
empresas para manter estoque acabou
dentro em gabinetes ar condicionados que
aceite a 4 nós não
nós vivemos no marajó olha as gerações e
nós nunca destruímos do marajó
nós nunca desprezamos marajó sabemos
viver com os nossos apetrechos e
mantendo essa comunidade viva agora para
isso nós precisamos ser nós temos só
para vocês terem uma idéia a nossa
produção ela é invisível aos olhos do
poder público
nós temos centenas de milhares de rasas
de açaí saindo todos os anos do marajó
nós temos centenas de produção de
farinha
nós temos a produção do peixe e do
camarão
só para vocês terem uma idéia só no meu
município entre as duas fronteiras na
zona de pesca
nós produzimos nós ficamos em média com
armadilha com a tap para quem conhece em
média de 150 e 180 mil a tap na água e
tudo isso geram uma quantidade de
camarão gigantesca mas nossa produção
some na hora de fatiar o poder a verba
pública
nossa produção é quantificada fora do
marajó é qualificada fora no marajó
só para vocês terem uma idéia nós aqui
mesmo da nossa cerâmica produzida aqui
embora se o queijo produzido em outro
lugar vão selando os nossos produtos e
ganhando milhões na forma enquanto não
há um retorno da nossa produção então
nossa briga não é pra que nós nos
isolemos do resto do planeta é que o
planeta vem é compartilhar com nós
porque hoje a mídia leva ao conhecimento
dos nossos jovens e da nossa população o
que acontece em todas as partes do
planeta mas não conhece o punho
chipp o vizinho o rio no lado a condição
do cabouco a moda o costume o hábito
o cabo está falando em outra língua mas
esqueceu da nossa realidade marajoara
eu nunca quero sair do marajó agora nós
vamos ter que nos adequar mas tem que
adequar o que está vindo de fora porque
a hora que nós conseguimos se pelo menos
enquadrar nossa briga que enquadre como
território pelo menos dentro da grade
curricular nas escolas alguma coisa que
é uma matéria que fala de meio ambiente
cultura marajoara não começar a inserir
novamente de volta por todas as nossas
histórias indígenas tribos nós só temos
de nossos costumes e alguns traços
físicos à la jogado nem o próprio fama
já pedimos que têm os cemitérios
arqueológicos tesos cara não vão lá
conferir verificar para poder dizer o
que nós somos
esse emaranhado de rios emaranhado de
labirinto que que é o marajó mas que é
único ele precisa ser visto de forma
igual mas tratado tratado politicamente
dentro das questões públicas com verba
recursos diferente porque a cada um real
que é aplicada numa zona numa área
metropolitana que é tratado dentro de um
contexto
a região sul é é 3 a 1
tem que gastar três para então nós
precisamos ter esse tratamento político
diferenciado na hora da distribuição das
verbas públicas porque o fotógrafo à
imprensa ou olha a costa da região de
campos onde tem ponto turístico ou
quando vai se tratar de prostituição
infantil que está na rota mas não desce
por uma plenária para discutir de fato e
de direito aquilo que é o direito do
cidadão major então a nossa identidade
nós passamos a cobrar dentro das redes
dentro da política territorial num
debate organizado um debate maduro em
todos os espaços gente que for possível
nós estaremos lá como cidadão como
pescador artesanal que sou e como
debatedor
não sei não tenho aquela titularidade de
de um bocado de coisas diz que foi
citado aqui de doutores e tudo mais mas
busco dentro da formação acadêmica dos
parceiros que respeito e sei que aqui
dentro
hoje já são profissionais ou vão buscar
se informar essa idéia de valorizar
nosso produto essa diversidade do marajó
que é única ela precisa ser respeitada
então esse é esse povo guerreiro que
veio dos maravilhosos usar essa casos
mais raros os classificados de uma
popular toda essa nossa história ela
está sendo depredada
os grandes empresários utilizam nossos
aí nossa farinha nosso camarão nossa
nossa cerâmica nossa dança nossa nossa
culinária selando fora nem o próprio
selo marajoara ainda não está sendo
respeitado e valorizado
dezenas de vezes no mercado externo e
interno e externo
mas esse não tem retorno para entrar
nessa briga por reconhecimento
valorização e por respeito a nossas
tradições
eu venho nesse campo de batalha com o
pescador artesanal como man movimento
social
só para vocês terem uma idéia esse nosso
produto nosso ouro negro no marajó sonho
e o único rio de curralinho lado
município que eu sou
ele exporta de maio a dezembro em torno
de 8 a 10 mil rasas de 14 quilo por dia
por dia
de agosto a dezembro é uma gigantesca e
que não volta para lá trabalhar nesse
processo nós buscamos alternativas
porque a violência impera dentro dos
nossos rios
a pirataria é somos alvos constantes
desse processo
então nesse contexto nós buscamos outras
alternativas de de sobreviver buscamos
dentro da da discussão social
encontramos parceiros que hoje nós temos
a bancos comunitários como é das
próprias para que fujamos desse processo
de sermos assaltados então nós
trabalhamos hoje lá no município de
muaná foi fundado banco para cuba no
município de curralinho nós temos o o
banco na tyco com a moeda e as a que é
só o povo que cadastro comerciante
cadastrado o produtor para a gente
tentar ver se não vira mais e que já é
constante alvo de assaltos dentro da
nossa região não estão buscando
alternativa e conseguimos também junto
com parceiros telecentro de informação
porque nós precisamos estar conectado
mas de forma que não venha a agredir e
deixar fora a nossa cultura nossa nós
precisamos de todos os parceiros mas os
parceiros precisam vir de forma
complementar que aquilo que já é nosso
aquilo que precisa ser respeitado estou
vindo aqui me colocando à disposição
como batalhador como movimento social e
dizer que aquele que precisa e quiser ir
com uma jóia nós temos em todos os
municípios parceiros pronto até no apoio
mas desde que venha na forma de nos
apoiar
eu preciso de todos esses que falaram
aqui sem exceção eu acompanhei aqui ela
precisou ir lá nas quebradas para achar
que o barco era melhor sair né então só
fazendo uma análise do que a gente tem
de tesouro valioso e que não têm lugar
nenhum do mundo é a nossa casa nossa
cozinha nossa culinária os outros tão
doido para vir ver mas precisamos dar
uma estrutura então em cima disso nossa
briga que a nossa luta e vamos continuar
deixo aqui o meu muito obrigado
professor
a equipe toda e estou disposto estamos
dispostos a ser parceiros e vamos
continuar na luta obrigado
[Aplausos]